[Musique]
avions fait cette femme en situation de
handicap mental cohabitent dans une
maison fraîchement rénovée elles sont
accompagnées de deux maîtresses de
maison pour les superviser un projet qui
vise à favoriser leur inclusion top
départ pour le tour auto 2022 leur
rendez vous des passionnés d'automobile
250 bolide de collection sont parties du
château de rambouillet nous rejoindrons
andorre la vieille et samedi 30 à avoir
arpenté la france la ville de villepoix
lancé son premier budget participatif
une initiative qui permet aux habitants
de la ville de proposer leurs projets
les dossiers peuvent se déposer en
mairie jusqu'au 15 juin seront ensuite
soumis à un vote la tournée des sites
olympiques de paris 2024 a débuté au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le président du comité d'organisation
tony estanguet étaient présents sur
place pour rappel saint quentin en
yvelines dispose de quatre sites
olympiques le vélodrome nationale le
stadium de bmx le golf national et la
colline de l'emploi c'est officiel
partenariat est signé cessange en branle
et qui va accueillir la délégation
olympique de la team grande bretagne
pour les jeux olympiques de paris 2024
les athlètes et les membres du comité
pourront s'entraîner bénéficier
d'équipements sportifs de haut niveau
[Musique]